el avión aterrizó el 6 de junio el lunes
6 de junio en argentina proveniente de
méxico con una carga de autopartes en el
viajaban 14 tripulantes de ciudadanía
venezolana y cinco tripulantes iraníes
en principio no había ninguna sospecha
el avión salió sin problemas de méxico
aterrizó sin problemas en argentina pasó
los controles aduaneros pero lo que
ocurrió es que cuando quisieron regresar
ninguna empresa local les proveyó el
combustible argumentando que venezuela
estaba sometido un bloqueo por parte de
estados unidos y se arriesgaban si lo
hacían así que intentaron el día 8 de
junio volar a uruguay pero uruguay no
les permitió aterrizar en ese país y
tuvieron que regresar además en paralelo
hay una causa judicial en argentina en
la que se investiga a estos cinco
ciudadanos iraníes cuyos pasaportes han
sido retenidos por el juez de la causa
sobre todo después de la decisión de
uruguay que no está claro que como
porque fue motivada de no permitirle
aterrizar al avión lo que despertó
mayores sospechas aquí
en la justicia argentina la realidad que
todavía no está muy claro cuál es el
motivo que puede hacer
retener y detener a estos ciudadanos
iraníes hay una sospecha de que alguno
pueda tener vínculos con la guardia
revolucionaria iraní pero el gobierno
argentino algunos voceros de gobierno
argentino han dicho que puede tratarse
de un homónimo algo que realmente
todavía no está claro la verdad que esta
es una situación una historia en la que
hay muchísimas preguntas sin respuestas
la información no termina de estar 100%
claro y por ahora lo que sabemos es que
el avión sin combustible no puede
regresar y esperamos por saber novedades
respecto a qué determinará la justicia
sobre estos ciudadanos iraníes